isil gunmen with semi-automatic weapons
drove into eastern iraq's remote village
of al-hawasha
and opened fire killing several people
all members of the same tribe
defenseless civilians is how iraqi
security services described them
at least 15 others were wounded
victory against isil was declared in
2017 but violence continues
one attack in july killed more than 30
people when a roadside bomb went off in
a crowded market in sauder city
it's very hard to tell from one incident
or two incidents
whether there's a pattern
we don't know that there's a resurgence
ten thousand isil fighters may still be
active in iraq and syria according to a
u.n estimate prime minister mustafa
al-khadami has promised to find the
perpetrators wherever they go
the influential shia cleric muktada
al-sadr whose soldiers block won the
most seats in parliamentary elections
this month says the village was targeted
by what he calls terrorists because
politicians too busy jockeying for power
neglected to focus on security
solder has banned armed groups from
using weapons outside of state control
but others are already taking action on
their own
videos shared on the messaging app
telegram appeared to show members of the
shia tribe attacking the neighboring
sunni village of nagar al-imam on
wednesday after accusing them of
facilitating the isil attack
a number of people were killed according
to local sources isil feeds on sunni
resentment of the shia
domination let's say of the political
system
and what i think is
perhaps
could happen is that the
shia militias now will say
there are isil attacks and we need to be
empowered to push back to fight back
against isil and they may use these
attacks
to have their own empowerment again
political parties linked to the
iran-backed popular mobilization forces
say they're willing to carry out broader
operations against isil after this
attack
andrew chappelle al jazeera